[Music]
this story is full of some crazy that's
what makes it so fun insatiable came
about as a script that made me feel seen
and heard and made me laugh but also
felt very much congruent with roy's I
wanted to be making I feel so free no I
was gonna say totally self-conscious I
have been God me too I think in media
everything is accessible and Lauren has
created this vehicle for us to
courageously with a sense of humor and
talk about anything and this doesn't
sound crazy to you when you say it Allah
there's such a conviction within the DNA
of it I found to be irresistible and the
beauty of the show is that it's about
finding yourself and it's a little
tongue in cheek it doesn't take itself
too seriously this is like every great
high school movie ever made for me it
was important to do it as a comedy but
also it needs to be rooted in real human
emotion I might be skinny on the outside
but on the inside I am still fatty patty
that's the thing that's tricky about the
show because there are moments of broad
comedy and also moments where you cry I
pride watching the show and I hope the
audience will cry too sometimes other
people see things in you that you can't
see for yourself we all have a fear of
being alone or if you're being forgotten
and I think people will see this the
same way that I did and say I'm not
alone be the most you you can be
insatiable could be anything and I think
in every single episode it looks
different and you'll find it in a
different place well I want to punch her
in her [ __ ] face insatiable is hunger
it's the profound emptiness down deep in
your soul it is impossible to satisfy Oh
write that down it's really about good
people who are making bad decisions
based on that hole in them I figured
that if I could share that pain in a way
that was funny and identifiable I was
hoping that people would feel less alone
you
[Music]
my name is patty high school was a
nightmare
patty Betty's huge while my classmates
were out losing their virginity I was at
home stuffing another hole smells like
bacon every day I wondered how much more
of this can I take then it hit me now
what right here
having my jaw wired shut lost me more
than just my summer vacation oh this is
like every great high school movie ever
made
now I could be the former fatty who
turned into a brain or an athlete or a
princess no I'd rather have revenge
[Applause]
[Music]
no petty is out of control
I want to punch her in her [ __ ] face I
want them to hurt like I hurt it anymore
I was insatiable what can I say
this story is full of some crazy
that's what makes it so fun
[Music]
you